foreign
what do we know about the prevention of
Alzheimer's disease so again we started
with a very bold hypothesis which we
were not alone in but most people
thought was crazy which was that these
diseases have some degree of prevention
there is a way to prevent these to some
extent maybe not completely but luck is
not the only thing or bad luck is not
the only thing that is driving these
diseases we have some control
and so to make a very long story short
after Dan kind of went through all of
this analysis and after analysis after
analysis
the thing that stood out above
everything else was the benefit of
exercise
and I just sort of told Dan to go back
to the drawing board I was kind of like
Dan I think he screwed this analysis up
buddy like there's zero chance that
exercise is actually the best thing here
like are you gonna now tell me that
chicken soup is the best thing for colds
like I wanted some insight here I didn't
want some stupid platitude right but it
turned out Dan was right and I was wrong
so I think I think the data are pretty
unambiguous you know in fact I'm doing a
podcast on this
I don't know by the time this one's out
it might be out I don't I don't know I
don't know but but I've got a podcast
coming out on sort of you know brain
health and here we are back again now
with you know many more analysts and
much more tools at our disposal to kind
of understand the literature and still
exercise remains
the most important modifiable Behavior
we have to reduce the risk of
Alzheimer's disease and probably
Parkinson's and Lewy Body Dementia by
the way so I can't say that for every
single neurodegenerative disease right I
can't I don't have any real insight into
how you prevent Lou Gehrig's Disease
which is an absolutely horrific disease
that is fortunately much more rare but
when it comes to the big three
Alzheimer's Parkinson's and Lewy Body
dementia
exercise exercise and exercise matter
and part of that has to do with movement
Reserve so you know when you think about
Lewy Body and Parkinson's these are
primarily movement disorders right so
they're kind of on a spectrum right
you've got Parkinson's at one end pure
movement disorder a little bit of
cognitive Lewy Body kind of bit of both
and then Alzheimer's much more cognitive
having a higher movement reserve and
having a higher cognitive Reserve are
protective
what do you mean by movement Reserve
just greater range of motion ability so
spectrum of movement patterns that they
can sustain greater physical capacity
right so you know people who are really
good dancers who are really good at
doing complicated coordinated
problem-solving things with their body
who have kinesthetic awareness
they're going to have a much slower
decline even when diagnosed with
Parkinson's disease for example
so we want our cognitive Reserve High we
want our movement Reserve High and then
on the other side of that you get the
sort of
kind of hormonal vascular metabolic
benefits that come from the actual
exercise so one is the benefits you get
from being in the state one is the
benefits you get accruing the state
could you could you spend a bit on the
hormonal effects and otherwise I mean I
think this is probably just because it
has words in the acronym that I like but
brain derived neurotrophic Factor Etc I
mean to what extent can you weight some
of these factors yeah I don't know that
I could tell you a relative waiting but
certainly bdnf is a very important one
so it's a very important you know
growth factor for neurons
but also of course when you think about
the metabolic effects and the hormonal
effects that come from
what is exercise doing to cortisol
levels what is exercise doing with
glucose and insulin levels I mean we we
see an unbelievably strong association
between Type 2 diabetes and Alzheimer's
disease well again here's an example of
where medicine 3.0 I think gives you a
little bit more confidence to make the
extension which is look if type 2
diabetes is bad
having insulin resistance without type 2
diabetes is also probably bad
and therefore we want to take all steps
possible to maximize insulin sensitivity
glucose disposal all of these things
that fit under the bucket of metabolic
health
and again exercise is not unique in its
ability to act on those things nutrition
absolutely does as well
but boy does exercise have a profound
effect on those things